bayern es el resultado de una larga
negociación entre eeuu y méxico nos van
a enviar dos millones setecientos mil
dosis
la semana próxima calculo que vamos a
tener esas vacunas hay una relación
también de respeto y de cooperación y
esta es una prueba
asiente el presidente andrés manuel
lópez obrador explicó que se trata de un
préstamo pues eeuu tiene almacenadas
dosis del fármaco que no se están
aplicando y que serán devueltas cuando
lleguen las vacunas que mexico le compro
astrazéneca ya tenemos contrato con
astrazéneca
millones de dosis pero para entregar
en el mediano plazo
entonces
se va a ser ahora en ese mismo contrato
con astrazéneca
se adelanta
las entregas
no es un contrato adicional
de acuerdo con el mandatario con esas
dosis y los demás envíos programados
méxico ya tiene suficientes vacunas para
cumplir con el objetivo de inocular a
todos los adultos mayores del país antes
del final de abril como está estipulado
en el plan nacional de vacunación
el fármaco de astrazéneca aún no ha sido
aprobado por las autoridades
estadounidenses por lo que el país tiene
excedentes de las dosis hasta el momento
méxico ha aplicado 4.9 millones de
vacunas el anuncio del envío coincide
con la entrada en vigor de nuevas
restricciones implementadas por méxico
en su frontera sur con guatemala y
belice en un nuevo intento por frenar
los flujos migratorios hacia eeuu